NOW TO A MASS SHOOTING IN
COLORADO SPRINGS, THE ONE
TARGETING AN LGBTQ NIGHTCLUB.
THE "DENVER POST" EDITORIAL
BOARD PENNED AN OP-ED QUOTING
WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU LAUREN
BOEBERT, STOP THE INTOLERANCE.
IT ACCUSES THE COLORADO
CONGRESSMAN OF NOT CARING WHERE
HER WORDS CAN LEAD.
SHE'S BEEN CRITICIZED FOR PAST
COMMENT ABOUT THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY, SHE'S ATTACKED
INCLUSIVE CLASSROOM PRACTICES,
MOCKED THE FIRST TRANCE GENDER
SENATE OFFICIAL.
BOB BERT SAYING IT WAS, QUOTE,
DISGUSTING TO TRY TO BLAME THE
SHOOTING ON HER AND IT WAS,
QUOTE, COMPLETELY FALSE TO SAY
SHE'S ATTACKED THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
BACK IN COLORADO SPRINGS, THE
SUSPECT, ANDERSON ALDRICH, NOW
BEING HELD WITHOUT BOND
FOLLOWING THEIR FIRST COURT
APPEARANCE.
FORMAL CHARGES ARE EXPECTED NEXT
MONTH.
CNN'S NICK WATT IS IN COLORADO
SPRINGS.
I UNDERSTAND YOU SPOKE TO THE
SUSPECT'S NEIGHBOR.
DID THEY SEE ANY SIGNS OF THIS?
WHAT DID THEY SAY?
>> WELL, YEAH, JIM, NOT JUST A
NEIGHBOR, A PRETTY CLOSE FRIEND.
THEY BONDED OVER VIDEO GAMES,
SPENT HOURS PLAYING GAMES
TOGETHER.
ONE THING THIS YOUNG MAN XAVIER
KRAUS TOLD ME, HE SAID THE
SUSPECT IS NOT SOMEONE I WOULD
HAVE AROUND MY GAY FRIENDS.
APPARENTLY HE HAD OCCASIONAL
OUTBURSTS OF ANGER.
HE USED SLURS TO DESCRIBE GAY
PEOPLE BUT ALSO HAD OUT BUST IS
ITS AGAINST OTHER RACES, ALSO.
XAVIER KRAUS IS A 24-YEAR-OLD
YOUNG MAN WITH A JOB.
HE SAID WHAT REALLY STRUCK HIM
WAS THE KIND OF DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN HIS LIFE AND THE
SUSPECT'S LIFE.
KRAUS LIVED IN AN APARTMENT WITH
HIS GIRLFRIEND.
HE HAS A JOB ACROSS THE HALLWAY.
THE SUSPSUSPECT, 22 YEARS OLD,
SIMILAR AGE, LIVED THERE WITH
HIS MOM AND DIDN'T APPEAR TO
HAVE ANY DIRECTION IN LIFE.
APPARENTLY THE SUSPECT VERY
SMART, BUT VERY ALONE.
FEW OTHER CONTACTS.
YOU KNOW, WE SAW DURING THE
APPEARANCE YESTERDAY BY VIDEO
LINK FROM THE JAIL CELL BEHIND
ME, THE SUSPECT WAS SLUMPED,
SLURRING, BRUISED HEAD.
WE'VE NOW ALSO SEEN THE MUG
SHOTS WHICH SHOW JUST HOW BEATEN
THIS SUSPECT WAS.
LET'S JUST TAKE US BACK TO THAT
NIGHT.
REMEMBER RICH FIERRO TOOK THE
SUSPECT DOWN AND THE SUSPECT WAS
KICKED REPEATEDLY IN THE HEAD BY
A YOUNG NAVAL OFFICER, TROM MASS
JAMES, AND A TRANSWOMAN WHOSE
NAME WE DON'T KNOW.
WE CAN SEE HOW BEATEN THE SPECK
WAS IN THAT PICTURE.
>> NO QUESTION.
NICK WATT, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AHEAD OF THAT, ATTORNEYS FOR THE
SHOOTER SUBMITTED A LETTER THAT
THE SUSPECT IDENTIFIES AS
BINARY.
AND WHEN ASKED IF IT WOULD
IMPACT THE PROSECUTION, THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SAID THIS.
>> IN EVERY MURDER CASE I HAVE
PROSECUTED, WHICH IS MORE THAN I
CARE TO TALK ABOUT.
I REFER TO EVERY ONE OF THOSE AS
DEFENDANTS, THAT'S WHAT I'LL DO
IN THIS CASE.
IT HAS NO IMPACT ON THE WAY I
PROSECUTE THIS CASE.
>> LET'S BRING IN JOEY JACKSON.
WE HEARD FROM THE DA WHO'S GOING
TO PROSECUTE THIS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS FILING?
>> I THINK HE'S RIGHT ON.
WE'LL HAVE THE DEFENDANT IN
COURT AND AT THAT TIME, I THINK
MORE CHARGES ARE TO COME.
AND THOSE CHARGES HAVE TO
REFLECT, POPPY, THE SPECIFICS OF
WHAT HE DID.
NOT ONLY AS IT RELATES TO THE
HORRIFIC DEATHS AT HIS HANDS BUT
EVERYONE ELSE WHO WAS IN DANGER.
EVERYONE ELSE WHOSE LIFE WILL
NOT BE THE SAME.
SO THE FACT IS YOU COULD
IDENTIFY HOWEVER YOU WANT, THIS
CASE IS GO ING TO FOCUS ON THE
EVIDENCE, THE FACTS AND
PREDICATED ON HIS ACTIONS.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FILING, THE
DEFENSE TEAM SAY NONBINARY.
SOME PEOPLE THINK THIS IS A PLOY
TO PUT STUFF IN THE MIX, CONFUSE
PEOPLE, MAKE PEOPLE FEEL SORRY
FOR HIM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> GOOD LUCK DO YOU THAT.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S A PLOY?
>> IT COULD BE.
GETTING BACK TO WHAT I SAID
ABOUT THE FACTS.
YOU CAN CALL YOURSELF WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL YOURSELF.
THIS CASE IS GOING TO FOCUS ON
WHAT YOU DID.
EVEN IF IF YOU CALL YOURSELF
THAT, PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY HAVE
INTERACTED WITH YOU THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS.
HAVE YOU IDENTIFIED YOURSELF AS
SUCH IN THAT WAY?
WHEN THERE WAS A PETITION FILED
WITH RESPECT TO THIS NAME
CHANGE, IT APPEARED AS THOUGH HE
IDENTIFIED AS MALE THEN.
SO THE FACT IS THAT HE CAN SAY
WHATEVER HE WANTS, WHAT DID YOU
DO?
THAT'S WHAT I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE ALL ABOUT.
LAST POINT AND THAT'S THIS.
REMEMBER THESE CHARGES ARE
MURDER CHARGES.
THE HATE CRIME ASPECT OF IT,
WHICH THERE SHOULD BE, YOU WANT
TO GIVE VOICE TO EVERYONE.
THAT JUST GOES TO ESTABLISH WHAT
YOUR MOTIVATIONS WERE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT IS
LIFE IN JAIL BECAUSE OF THE
ACTIONS, IF PROVEN IN A COURT OF
LAW, THAT HE COMMITTED.
>> BUT THEY'D BE AGGRAVATING.
IN COLORADO IT'S CALLED A BIAS
MOTIVATED CRIME.
AS I UNDERSTAND, THE SUSPECT HAS
NOT TALKED TO POLICE.
HOW HIGH IS THE BAR TO PROVE IT
IF YOU HAVE THE SUSPECT NOT
TALKING?
>> IN THIS DISTRICT THEY MADE IT
LESS.
IN 2021 HUH TO DEMONSTRATE IT
WAS THE SOLE MOTIVATING FACTOR
BEHIND WHAT YOU WERE DOING.
NOW IT IS A FACTOR AS RELATES TO
WHAT YOUR ACTIVITIES ARE.
SO I THINK THE BAR IS DIFFERENT.
TO YOUR QUESTION IT'S NOT ONLY
GETTING A DEFENDANT TO TALK,
MANY DON'T.
US DEFENSE ATTORNEYS DON'T LIKE
OUR CLIENTS TO TALK.
BUT THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES YOU CAN EVALUATE.
WHAT DID YOU TARGET THAT
PARTICULAR NIGHT, WHO DID YOU
TARGET, WHY WERE YOU THERE?
WERE THEY CELEBRATING SOMETHING,
AS THEY WERE ON THAT OCCASION,
IN TERMS OF THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY AND A REMEMBRANCE
NIGHT, DID YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT?
DID PEOPLE -- WERE PEOPLE WHO
ARE FAMILIAR WITH YOU, DID THEY
EXPRESS CONCERNS ABOUT HOW YOU
FELT ABOUT MEMBERS OF THE GAY
COMMUNITY.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO TALK BUT I
THINK HIS ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDLY
IF HE'S NOT.
>> THANK YOU, JOEY JACKSON.
>> HAPPY THANKSGIVING.